herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zur Pressekonferenz herzlich
willkommen zur Pressekonferenz nach den
Gremien heute mit dem CDU-Vorsitzenden
Ministerpräsident Armin Laschet und
Generalsekretär Paul ziemiak jetzt gibt
es erst ein Bericht aus den Gremien im
Anschluss gibt es Gelegenheit für Fragen
ja meine Damen und Herren wir haben
heute im Präsidium und dem
Bundesvorstand der CDU intensiv über die
Wahlergebnisse von gestern und über das
weitere Vorgehen gesprochen steht völlig
außer Frage dieses Ergebnis kann darf
und wird die Union nicht
zufriedenstellen wir haben zwar im
schlusssprucht eine Aufholjagd geschafft
und
Rot-Rot-Grün verhindert aber zugleich
gibt es schmerzliche Verluste es hat
nicht gereicht für Platz 1 das war unser
Anspruch das war unsere Ambition und
mein Glückwunsch geht an die
mitbewerbenden Parteien die zugelegt
haben bei dieser Wahl ein Ergebnis unter
30 Prozent ist nicht der Anspruch der
Union als Volkspartei besonders
drastisch sind die Verluste in
Ostdeutschland ausgefallen
die Gründe für dieses Wahlergebnis sind
vielschichtig auch das ist heute in den
Wortmeldungen der vielen vielen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen des
Bundesvorstands deutlich geworden und
natürlich weiß ich auch dass ich meinen
persönlichen Anteil an diesem
Wahlergebnis habe wir haben besprochen
dass wir das alles intensiv aufarbeiten
das werden wir tun in einem
strukturierten Prozess mit den
Landesverbänden mit den Kreisverbänden
und mit anderen an der Basis der
Generalsekretär wird dazu gleich noch
etwas sagen und das werden wir tun ganz
gleich ob wir am Ende dieses Prozesses
in Regierungsverantwortung sind oder in
der Opposition auch in
Regierungsverantwortung muss eine
Erneuerung der Union stattfinden auf
allen Ebenen und das ist das was wir
dann gemeinsam besprechen werden
das ist die Verantwortung die wir gehen
über unsere Partei haben aber es gibt
auch eine Verantwortung für unsere
Wählerinnen und Wähler eine
Verantwortung für unser Land die
Wählerinnen und Wähler die CDU und CSU
gewählt haben wollen dass wir auch
Verantwortung übernehmen und regieren
und wir sind der Überzeugung dass eine
Führung
eine Regierung unter Führung der Union
das Beste ist für unser Land und auch
diesen Wählern fühlen wir uns
verpflichtet und deshalb haben wir
gestern unsere Bereitschaft dazu erklärt
das Ergebnis der Bundestagswahl stellt
nämlich nicht nur die Union sondern auch
Deutschland vor große Herausforderungen
bei fast jeder Bundestagswahl war am
Ende klar eine Partei hat einen klaren
Regierungsauftrag hat eine Mehrheit die
muss jetzt regieren und die andere hat
die Oppositionsrolle zugewiesen bekommen
für uns können wir sagen keine Partei
kann aus diesem klaren
Ergebnis für sich einen
Regierungsauftrag ableiten auch wir
nicht auch das habe ich gestern deutlich
gemacht
auch die SPD nicht es ist ein Moment wo
gerade die beiden großen Volksparteien
die den ansprachlich haben müssten um
die 30 Prozent zu liegen mit Demut vor
den Wähler treten müssen und sagen
müssen nein diese großen Volksparteien
die über 30 Prozent bei früheren Wahlen
immer gehabt haben haben diesmal dieses
Ziel nicht erreicht die einen bei 24 und
die anderen bei 25 und deshalb ist jetzt
der Wahlkampf vorbei keiner sollte so
auftreten als wenn er alleine
entscheiden könnte wie er eine Regierung
bildet und deshalb sind Gespräche mit
möglichen Partnern jetzt erforderlich
wir müssen uns da auf Augenhöhe begegnen
wir müssen auch Gegensätze überwinden
zwischen unterschiedlichen politischen
Strömungen eine nächste Bundesregierung
wird ja aller Voraussicht nach drei
große parteifamilien miteinander
verbinden müssen und der Schatz in
dieser Form nach einer Bundestagswahl in
Deutschland bisher auch nicht gegeben
klar ist
Kanzler wird in Deutschland der der eine
Mehrheit im Deutschen Bundestag hinter
sich bringt so ist unsere Verfassung so
ist unsere Staatspraxis seit Gründung
unseres Landes und Kanzler kann auch nur
der werden dem es gelingt Gegensätze zu
verbinden und ein gutes gemeinsames
Projekt für die nächsten vier Jahre zu
entwickeln
der Bundesvorstand das Präsidium
der CDU ist sich darin einig dass wir zu
Gesprächen für eine sogenannte
Jamaika-Koalition bereitstehen
und meine Praxis als Regierungschef
jetzt war es immer dass sich jeder
Partner auch wiederfinden muss in einer
solchen Koalition dass jeder auf sein
Profil entwickeln muss dass nicht alles
nur auf die Person des Regierungschefs
zugeschnitten sein darf sondern dass
jeder Partner mit seinen Themen auch
vorkommen muss eine Koalition ist keine
Zwangsehe und ist auch keine
Arithmetik wo man einfach addiert wie
viel passt denn zusammen und am Ende
sind das über 50 Prozent sondern eine
Koalition muss ein politisches Projekt
sein
wo auch und das ist ein Gegensatz zur
großen Koalition jetzt alle den Willen
haben und auch die Lust haben etwas
positives für das Land zu gestalten und
nicht ständig den Eindruck vermitteln
dass man eigentlich gar nicht regieren
will und dass das eigentlich alles
freudlos ist und deshalb glaube ich dass
wir zu einer gesellschaftlichen Breite
mit einem Jamaika-Bündnis beitragen
könnten dafür sind zwei
Schlüsselbegriffe prägend das eine ist
zukunftskoalition und das andere ist
Nachhaltigkeit Deutschland muss
modernisiert werden deutschland braucht
eine Koalition für mehr Nachhaltigkeit
und das in jeder Hinsicht nachhaltigkeit
heißt Klimaschutz nachhaltigkeit heißt
aber auch nachhaltige Finanzpolitik
keine Finanzpolitik zu Lasten künftiger
Generationen auch das muss eine künftige
Koalition prägen wir brauchen mehr Tempo
bei Digitalisierung Planungen wir wissen
alle dass das alles viel zu langsam geht
und eine neue Koalition muss sich dieses
Ziel setzen und wir brauchen auch das
wichtige Anliegen dass wir zu
wirtschaftlichem Wachstum wieder
zurückkommen das ist ein besonderes
Anliegen der FDP dass wir teilen bei den
Grünen teilen wir das Engagement für den
Klimaschutz und die Umwandlung unseres
industrielands zu einem klimaneutralen
Industrieland
zum weiteren Vorgehen wir sind im
Gespräch wir werden die Gespräche sicher
auch noch formalisiert in den nächsten
Tagen fortsetzen aber hier ist mir
wichtig das darf nicht das Kleinklein
sein dass wir aus früheren Sondierungen
kennen
vier Wochen lang sondieren mit
Verhandlungen über jeden kleinen
kommastrich mit vielen eckigen Klammern
was alles nicht gelöst ist und am Ende
dann eine gescheiterte Sondierung kann
ich das Verfahren dieses Mal sein wir
brauchen
Gespräche aus denen deutlich werden muss
trauen sich die jeweiligen Partner das
zu das gemeinsam zu machen ja oder nein
ganz wesentlich eine Frage des
Vertrauens man wird die Inhalte
abgleichen und dann vielleicht sehr bald
auch Klarheit haben mit wem man
Koalitionsverhandlungen aufnimmt
das war das was ich in
Nordrhein-Westfalen gemacht habe was
meine Erfahrung ist auch in einer
Regierung viele Themen die man im
Koalitionsvertrag verabredet spielen in
den vier Jahren Häufigkeit keine rolle
ich habe ja gestern einmal das Beispiel
genannt Pandemie war keine Frage die im
kollisionsvertrag eine Rolle spielte sie
hat zwei Jahre fast der Politik
dominiert davor war es die
flüchtlingskrise davor war es die Welt
Finanzkrise alles Dinge die nicht im
Koalitionsvertrag standen aber die
trotzdem im Moment als es darauf ankam
klar gemacht haben die Akteure die da
regieren haben so viel Vertrauen
zueinander dass sie diese Krise zusammen
bewältigen und das ist die Voraussetzung
eine gute Koalition zu machen und das
werden solche Sondierungen ergeben
müssen unabhängig natürlich von den
großen Themen wie Wirtschaftswachstum
wie sozialer Zusammenhalt wie Klimakrise
dazu wird man ein paar Rahmenbedingungen
natürlich abstimmen müssen aber
entscheidend ist trauen sich die Akteure
des gegenseitig zu jetzt ein neues
Projekt für das Land zu beginnen
zu dem was wir in der Partei
weitermachen spricht ist gleich der
Generalsekretär mein Dank gilt normalen
Wählerinnen und Wählern auch den
Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten wir haben
manche Wahlkreise verloren von
engagierten Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
gekämpft haben aber die am Ende nicht
gewinnen konnten
die Enttäuschung dort können wir alle
verstehen und wir werden jetzt gemeinsam
sehen wie wir auch individuell bei denen
sind die ihr Mandat verloren haben wenn
dann gilt auch allen Wahlkämpferinnen
und Wahlkämpferin
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und in Berlin wo
ja ebenfalls gestern gewählt worden ist
danke auch den Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern hier im Hause die letzten
Wochen wirklich Großes geleistet haben
wir haben deutlich gemacht dass wir als
Team antreten dieser Teamgedanke ist mir
auch in der weiteren Entwicklung der
Union sehr wichtig und heute haben auch
noch mal die Strömung der Partei sich
artikuliert die sagen wir wollen
Vorkommen der christlich-soziale Flügel
stark durch Karl Josef Laumann der
Wirtschaftsflügel der seine Punkte
gesetzt hat und der Liberale und
Konservative Flügen hatte ebenfalls
spreche heute man konnte daran erkennen
die Volkspartei wird jetzt definieren
wie sie sich in Zukunft aufstellt die
Erneuerung kann stattfinden sie kann
auch in einer Regierung stattfinden sie
muss sogar auch wenn wir regieren
dringend umgesetzt werden
erzähl mir ja vielen Dank meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren auch ich
möchte mit einem dank beginnen an die
Wählerinnen und Wähler aber natürlich
auch an die Wahlkämpferinnen und
Wahlkämpfer überall in Deutschland für
die Union und an die
kandidatinnenkandidaten die vor Ort ein
unglaublich engagierten Wahlkampf
geführt haben und gekämpft haben vor Ort
für die Idee der CDU und dafür danken
wir ihn ich danke den Mitarbeiterinnen
Mitarbeitern ebenso das
konrad-adenauer-hauses die an
unglaublich engagierten Einsatz gezeigt
haben die tolle Arbeit geleistet haben
die Tag- und Nacht da waren um alles zu
tun damit wir einen guten Wahlkampf
machen können an ihnen hat es nicht
gelegen und ich möchte an dieser Stelle
auch an die denken die es nicht
geschafft haben die nicht in den
Deutschen Bundestag wiedergewählt wurden
oder hinein gewählt wurden trotz ihres
unglaublichen Einsatzes und deswegen ist
es wichtig zu sagen dass die Gründe
nicht vor Ort zu suchen sind sondern
woanders und deswegen müssen wir dieses
Wahlergebnis aufarbeiten
und dieses aufarbeiten bedeutet eine
klare und schonungslose Analyse es gibt
aus meiner Sicht überhaupt kein Grund
irgendwas schön zu reden die Verluste
die wir erlitten haben im Vergleich auch
zur letzten Bundestagswahl sie sind
bitter und sie tun weh und deswegen
müssen wir uns
genau auch Bewusstsein wo wir wie viel
verloren haben wenn ich zum Beispiel an
den Osten denke dann treibt mich das
sehr um die Frage spielten die Themen
die für die Menschen dort eine Rolle
spielen ausreichend hatten sie
ausreichend Platz in unserem Wahlkampf
die Frage der besonderen Strukturen dort
wie geht es dort jetzt weiter nachdem
viele Mandate verloren gegangen sind
dass es etwas was mich sehr beschäftigt
und ich finde dass die Frage wie ist die
CDU im Osten aufgestellt eine ganz ganz
wichtige ist deswegen braucht es jetzt
eine wie gesagt schonungslose
konsequente Analyse dieses
Wahlergebnisses das ist nicht mit einer
Sitzung beendet und diese muss auch
brutal offen sein
deshalb müssen wir die Kampagne
evaluieren wir müssen vor Ort uns auch
der Diskussion stellen das ist heute
auch noch mal in der Sitzung klar
geworden und das werde ich auch als
Generalsekretär tun vor Ort zu sein mit
denjenigen sprechen auch die jeden Tag
vor Ort Wahlkampf gemacht haben das sind
die Kreisverbände stellvertretend die
Kreisvorsitzenden die Ortsvorsitzenden
diese Gespräche diese Konferenzen werden
jetzt ganz ganz wichtig sein und bei
allem Respekt auch für die gewählten
Gremien die ganz wichtig sind eine
Aufarbeitung und eine Wahlanalyse kann
nicht in erster Linie nur durch die
Gremien erfolgen sondern sie muss die
ganze Partei einbinden insbesondere die
Basis die ich gerade angesprochen habe
und ich finde wir müssen auch mit den
Vereinigungen sprechen der die
unterschiedlichen Flügel und Strömungen
unserer Partei repräsentieren mit all
ihren Themen insbesondere denke ich da
auch an die jungen Menschen die hier
gemeinsam mit der Jungen Union tollen
Job gemacht haben bei unserem
connect-team die Frage wie wir auch
junge Leute erreichen treibt mich sehr
sehr um und deswegen braucht es in der
Frage der Partei die klare offene
Analyse aber eben auch Erneuerung für
die Zukunft der Union als Volkspartei
der Mitte und das werden wir jetzt tun
in einem sehr strukturierten Prozess
worüber wir auch noch in dieser Woche
beraten werden und dieser Prozess muss
sehr intensiv sein und wie gesagt alle
einbinden und diese Sitzung war geprägt
eben von Selbstkritik Selbstkritik in
Bezug auf die Verluste gestern Abend
aber sie war auch geprägt diese Sitzung
von einem großen Bewusstsein von
Verantwortung und staatspolitischer
Verantwortung für dieses Land es gibt
mehrere Optionen eine neue Regierung zu
bilden und wir haben diesen Geist heute
gespürt dass wir mit einem starken
Wahlprogramm von CDU und CSU antreten
sind und bereit sind diesem Land zu
dienen gemeinsam mit anderen Partnern
auf Augenhöhe um eine mögliche Zukunfts
ein mögliches zukunftsbündnis für
Sicherheit für Klimaschutz und für
Innovationen auf den Weg zu bringen aber
das werden die Gespräche zeigen und
diese beiden Punkte waren heute
Kernbestandteil und diese Aufgabe ist
jetzt herausfordernd beides ist
herausfordernd aber beides ist auch
wichtig und deswegen werden wir die
nächsten Tage und Wochen sehr intensiv
arbeiten
vielen Dank ich habe sehr viele Fragen
einige davon können wir an den beginnen
wir mit Frau Hirscher vom ZDF und danach
der Herr Rinke bitte Frau häfer
sie haben gesagt dass sie mit Demut vor
den Wähler auch treten warum machen Sie
nicht den Anfang und bekennen dass sie
Zweiter geworden sind wir können Sie das
vor sich moralisch rechtfertigen
trotzdem Platz eins zu beanspruchen nein
ich beantworte nicht Platz eins wir sind
Platz zwei
aber eine Koalition bildet sich an
sachinhalten und aus der Mehrheit des
Deutschen Bundestages und das kann man
nur in Gesprächen jetzt klären wer denn
im Deutschen Bundestag eine Mehrheit hat
und wenn der eine 24 hat und der andere
25 hat mich automatisch der der 25 hat
eine Mehrheit im Bundestag das ist ja
nur durch
sachgespräche lösbar am Ende über 50%
der Mandat im Deutschen Bundestag zu
bekommen und das ist die Aufgabe vor der
jetzt alle demokratischen Parteien
stehen es ist sehr gut dass dieser
Prozess ohne die extremen funktionieren
kann unter den Demokraten in der Mitte
aber wenn ich auch die Signale aus den
anderen Parteien wahrnehme ist genau der
Wille da diese Gespräche zu führen und
dazu ist die CDU bereit
dann Herr Rinke von Reuters bitte
er Laschet sie haben gesagt dass sie
sondieren wollen mit Grünen und FDP es
gibt aber gleichzeitig die Warnung dass
eine jetzt starke schwächte Union hier
in Markenkern dann endgültig aufgeben
könnte fürchten sie nicht dass das genau
die Konsequenz ist und sie zwingen wird
letztlich selber den Stecker zu ziehen
bei diesen Sondierungsgesprächen nein
ja wir werden natürlich unseren
Markenkern nicht aufgeben für ein
klimaneutrales Industrieland einzutreten
für
Sicherheit in Deutschland einzutreten
für ein europäisches Deutschland
einzutreten für Tempo bei der
Digitalisierung und Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigen
einzutreten dass man die Kernthemen des
Wahlkampfs das halte ich mit beiden
Partnern sowohl mit den Grünen als auch
mit der FDP für lösbar
dann bitte Frau Lehmann von der neuen
Osnabrücker Zeitung
wie groß halten Sie denn den Rückhalt
jetzt im Vorstand einem Präsidium für
sie jetzt in diese Sondierungen
reinzugehen und wie groß ist der
Rückhalt in der Partei dafür dass die
Parteichef bleiben
der Rückhalt des Präsidiums und des
Bundesvorstands ist ohne jede
Gegenstimme für diese Gespräche erfolgt
das ist nicht formal abgestimmt worden
aber am Ende hat es meine
Zusammenfassung den Konsens aller
befunden und es hat auch in der Sitzung
keiner daran Zweifel geäußert dass die
Union in dieser Lage ihre Bereitschaft
zur Regierungsbildung erklären muss
von Spiegel
morgen kommt die neue Fraktion von
cdu/csu zusammen da steht eigentlich die
Wahl eines Fraktionsvorsitzenden an und
haben sie im Präsidium vorgeschlagen
dass man auf diese Wahl verzichten soll
und der bisherige Amtsinhaber Brinkhaus
erstmal im Amt bleiben soll Ralf
Brinkhaus hat offensichtlich gesagt er
möchte trotzdem kandidieren was wird
denn nun morgen passieren
schön dass sie mir berichten was im
Präsidium war im Präsidium war es nicht
so wie sie es schildern in Präsidium
habe ich vorgeschlagen dass Ralf
Brinkhaus in der Phase dieser
Koalitionsverhandlungen
Fraktionsvorsitzender sein soll wie wir
das formell machen werden wir im Laufe
des Tages heute noch besprechen aber es
ist doch korrekt das Ralf Brinkhaus
gesagt hat er möchte antreten
der erste Teil ihrer Beschreibung war
nicht korrekt
das erste Teil war also ich glaube
bitte nochmal gehen Sie davon aus dass
Ralf Brinkhaus Morgen als
Fraktionsvorsitzende Ralf Brink aus
morgen vorschlagen als
Fraktionsvorsitzenden zusammen mit dem
bayerischen Ministerpräsident das steht
da außer Frage ich habe ja aber gestern
Abend schon gesagt dass ich selbst für
dieses Amt nicht zur Verfügung stehe
ähnlich wie Olaf Scholz also ich führe
die Gespräche als Parteivorsitzender
Olaf Scholz führt sie weder als
Parteivorsitzender noch als
Fraktionschef wenn er auch nicht
Fraktionschef werden will sondern als
Kanzlerkandidat deshalb müssen wir die
Gespräche muss die SPD die Gespräche
hier auch über ihre Parteivorsitzenden
führen und für uns ist klar dass ich
diese Sondierung führen kann aus dem Amt
des Parteivorsitzenden und ich es gut
finde wenn Ralf Brinkhaus als
Fraktionsvorsitzender an diesem
Gesprächen beteiligt ist und das werden
wir morgen der Fraktion vorschlagen aber
das heißt muss man nachfragen für die
Klarheit dass er kommissarisch im Amt
bleiben soll das werden wir bis morgen
klären in welcher Form wir diese
Abstimmung machen mir ist wichtig dass
Ralf brinkers dabei ist und für die
Fraktion an diesem Gesprächen teilnimmt
was anders war aber seit gestern nie
geplant insofern war die einleitende
Bemerkung heute morgen gab es da
irgendeines gut gegeben falsch meine
Meinung ist seit gestern dass es richtig
ist in dieser Phase der Ungewissheit wer
denn in Zukunft regiert oder wer
Opposition ist so eine Lage haben wir ja
in Deutschland noch nie gehabt dass da
Kontinuität in der Fraktion ist und dass
diese Kontinuität durch Ralf Brinkhaus
verkörpert wird
Herr blank von dpa verlor ich muss noch
mal nachfragen zu den möglichen
Gesprächen die anstehen weil gestern
haben sie doch den Eindruck erweckt dass
man auch parallel mit Herrn Scholz
zusammen mit den Grünen und der FDP als
Union verhandeln könnte heute hört sich
das etwas anders an dass man erst
abwartet ob die Gespräche von Herrn
Scholz erfolgreich sind ist das so und
was besprechen sie denn sie haben gesagt
sie haben mit Herrn Lindner schon
gesprochen und werden noch mit Frau
Berber sprechen geht es da schon am
Inhalte oder was werden sie da
besprechen oder haben sie gesprochen
danke ich habe gestern nicht den
Anhänger erweckt als wenn ich erst mit
Herrn Scholz reden wollte oder ob ich
irgendwas abwarten
nein ich habe nicht gesagt mit Herrn
Scholz sondern dass sie parallel mit
Herrn Scholz mit den Grünen und der FDP
reden mit wem es sich denn lohnt
Koalitionsverhandlungen
ich weiß nicht wann wer mit wem mit wem
herr Schulz redet ich habe für uns
gestern deutlich gemacht dieses Ergebnis
wenn man auf Platz zwei liegt ist kein
Regierungsauftrag und wir erheben auch
keinen Anspruch auch wenn es so
geschrieben wurde mein Wort wird gestern
war sehr präzise es gibt kein Anspruch
wer Platz 2 hat kein Anspruch aber es
ist eine Situation wo der eine 24 und
der andere 25 hat und die beiden kleinen
Partner gesagt haben das ist nicht
automatisch so dass einer für sich da
beanspruchen kann er redet jetzt mal mit
den kleinen und deshalb haben FDP und
Grüne gestern deutlich gemacht sie
wollen erstmal miteinander reden was ich
in Ordnung finde und es wird parallel es
gibt Gespräche mit jedem erst einmal
über die über das weitere Vorgehen und
dann wird irgendwann entschieden wie
geht es denn strukturiert weiter aber da
gibt es jetzt keine Reihenfolge gestern
gab es Gespräche heute gibt es Gespräche
morgen gibt es Gespräch es wird immer
wieder Gespräche geben formalisiert wenn
ich es richtig verstehe was die
Wettbewerber sagen treffen sich jetzt
erstmal FDP und Grüne
so deshalb ist nichts anderes als
gestern und es ist auch nichts anders
als morgen es ist eine Lage die
Deutschland so noch nicht erlebt hat und
auf die nebenbei neben all unseren
Kleinen ganz Europa blickt wir müssen
auch ausstrahlen dass Deutschland eine
regierungsfähige Regierung bekommen wird
eine handlungsfähige Regierung weil die
Aufgaben in Europa ja nicht warten und
natürlich alle darauf achten dass
Stabilität in Deutschland herrscht
deshalb ist das mit muss das mit hohem
Verantwortungsbewusstsein auch diese
Gespräche geführt werden und das ist
meine Absicht und unsere Bereitschaft
als Union unseren Beitrag dazu zu
leisten
dann Frau Dunz von der Rhein in der
Mitte rnd genau
Herr Laschet warum entscheiden Sie sich
dagegen dass Herr Brinkhaus wie es
bisher üblich war zum Anfang einer
Legislaturperiode der
Fraktionsvorsitzende für ein Jahr
gewählt wird sie haben ja gesagt für die
Phase der koalitionsverhandlung was
macht das so unsicher ihn heute schon zu
bestimmen und wie reagieren sie auf die
Mahnungen von ihren
cdu-parteikollegen wie zum Beispiel Herr
Kretschmer und Herr Haseloff jetzt doch
inne zu halten und einmal in Ruhe zu
überlegen wo die Union sich wiederfinden
muss nämlich unter Umständen bei einer
Erneuerung in der Opposition das haben
die heute nicht vorgetragen sie erhalten
es für richtig alle beide dass die Union
ihrer Bereitschaft erklärt angesichts
dieses Wahlergebnisses nun mit anderen
Parteien zu sprechen und zu sondieren
wie eine nächste Bundesregierung
gebildet wird
das war heute einhellige Auffassung der
beiden von Ihnen zitierten und zum
anderen in welchem Verfahren wir den
Fraktionsvorsitzenden wählen habe ich
eben gesagt ist noch nicht klar wir
werden darüber heute noch Gespräche
führen
ja weil wir darüber Gespräche führen
müssen weil es eine außergewöhnliche
Situation ist weil man normalerweise am
Tag nach der Wahl weiß ob man Regierung
und ob es oder Opposition ist so ist es
bei allen Wahlen in Deutschland in der
Regel dass man nach dem Wahltag weiß
sind wir jetzt Opposition oder sind wir
Regierung und diese Frage ist am
heutigen Tag noch nicht beantwortet und
deshalb müssen wir jetzt auch unseren
Partnern in den Gesprächen gegenüber
signalisieren die CDU und die CSU sind
handlungsfähig und deshalb werden wir
auch den Weg des Fraktionsvorsitzenden
gemeinsam da gehen
dann noch zwei für zwei drei Fragen dann
bitte der Herr Delfs von Blumenberg
was machen Sie denn eigentlich jetzt mit
ihrer mit ihrer Aufgabe in NRW also wenn
sie jetzt in der Tat den Gespräche hier
in Berlin mit den verschiedenen Parteien
eintreten werden sie ja kaum mehr Zeit
haben und Energie die
Regierungsgeschäfte in Düsseldorf
weiterzuführen und wenn sie jetzt auch
nicht für den Fraktionsvorsitz
kandidieren was passiert dann eigentlich
mit ihnen wenn diese Gespräche hier
scheitern also wenn es keine
Regierungsamt in Berlin gibt also ich
habe in diesem Wahlkampf sehr darauf
geachtet all die Wochen und Monate dass
ich meine Aufgaben als Ministerpräsident
von Nordrhein-Westfalen sehr ernsthaft
weiterführer bis hin zu jeder
Kabinettssitzung und zum Bearbeiten
jedes Vorgangs trotz eines anspannenden
Bundestagswahlkampfs und deshalb können
Sie davon ausgehen dass ich das auch in
der nächsten Zeit bis zu einem Wechsel
im Amt des Ministerpräsidenten in vollem
Umfang machen werde
dann die vorletzte Frage an Herrn Otto
von ZEIT ONLINE ja hallo Herr Laschet
gerne eine ja Nein Antwort von Ihnen sie
haben das so verklausuliert angedeutet
aber können Sie ausschließen als als
Vizekanzler unter Olaf Scholz in eine
Regierung einzutreten
wir schließen überhaupt nichts aus unter
Demokraten aber eines ist doch klar
diese Gespräche finden und gerade nicht
statt es werden Gespräche stattfinden
vor allem mit FDP und Grünen und ich
glaube die andere Variante ist keine die
jetzt auf den Prioritätenlisten der
beiden großen Volksparteien die sie
einmal waren steht
wenn Herrmann da vorne von der
Süddeutschen Zeitung welches richtig
sehe ganz hinten die letzte Frage dann
Herr Laschet was was passiert denn jetzt
mit dem zukunftsteam gibt es das noch
ist die Zukunft des Teams gegen die bis
gestern oder geht die weiter
zukunftsteams sind zukunftsteams
bedauer des Joe cialo nicht den
Wahlkreis Spandau gewonnen hat er hätte
die Bundestagsfraktion bereichert
und
wie wir jetzt weitermachen wie die
Akteure einige sind ja Mitte des
Bundesvorstands die klimaunion wird auch
wenn Wiebke Winter leider den Wahlkreis
Bremen nicht gewonnen hat eine wichtige
Rolle natürlich auch in möglichen
Gesprächen für eine Jamaika-Koalition
spielen also jeder der Friedrich Merz
ist jetzt Mitglied des Deutschen
Bundestages so können Sie jeden
einzelnen abrufen jeder wird auch in der
Neuaufstellung in der Reform in allem
was wir jetzt in der Union planen seine
Rolle spielen wenn ich nur Einsatz nur
noch dazu ergänzen kann wir haben gerade
ja im Bundesvorstand dazu gesprochen
auch über die Arbeit der
strukturensatzungskommissionen einige
von ihnen erinnern sich als wir über die
Frage Repräsentanz von Frauen in die
Frage wie sieht die Zukunft der Partei
aus diesen Prozess müssen wir jetzt umso
mehr weiter vorantreiben also diese
Erneuerung und da wird natürlich
diejenigen die jetzt auch in dem
zukunftsteam waren mit all ihren Ideen
und Kompetenzen müssen daher eine Rolle
spielen und natürlich diejenigen die in
der Breite der Partei jeden Tag arbeiten
so dann habe ich doch noch Zeit für zwei
Fragen denn Herr Strauß bitte von der
Saarbrücker Zeitung
Laschet ich wollte sie mal anfragen wie
es ihnen überhaupt geht wie verarbeiten
sie emotional diese derbe Niederlage sie
sind ja eine rheinische Frohnatur prallt
das alles an ihnen ab oder würden Sie
sich am liebsten verkriechen also wie
geht's ihnen naja ich hätte gerne auf
Platz eins gelegen und dass dieses Jahr
ein
besonders intensives ist gibt ja viele
Analysen wir hier am meisten
auch an
Attacken und hassattacken und ähnlichem
entgegengenommen hat das schon etwas was
einen berührt aber es war uns ja immer
klar dass ab dem Moment wo Angela Merkel
das Amt verlässt alle Kräfte von rechts
und links bei mir am Anfang immer eher
stark von rechts inzwischen auch von
anderen verhindert wird dass jemand von
der CDU Kanzler wird
das habe ich auch zu spüren bekommen
ich hätte gerne jetzt auf Platz eins
gelegen aber
die Verpflichtung wenn man so knapp
hinten liegt jetzt weiter an einer guten
Lösung für einen gute Regierung zu
arbeiten da hat mich heute das Präsidium
und der Bundesvorstand einhellig
unterstützt und das gibt einem in
solchen Momenten dann auch die Kraft
diesen Auftrag zu erfüllen
denn die letzte Frage an die Dame in der
Mitte nehmen genau sehr gut
ich würde gerne noch mal zu den
Gesprächen kommen zu den
jamaika-gesprächen diese gegebenenfalls
führen wollen sie haben gesagt dass man
sich auf Augenhöhe begegnen muss kann
die Union aus dieser Position der
Schwäche heraus überhaupt Augenhöhe
erreichen wenn sie sagen dass Grün und
Gelb jetzt gerade schon Gespräche führen
sieht das dann nicht eher danach aus als
würde das Gespräche sein die unter
grün-gelben Gnaden Geschehen na die
beiden früheren kleineren Parteien haben
sehr gute Ergebnisse erzielt aber die
Frage ist ja führt man mit 24 Prozent
ein Gespräch aus der Position der
Schwäche oder der Stärke um mit 25% ein
völlig anderes Gespräch also Olaf Scholz
und ich sind finde ich zur gleichen
Demut aufgerufen in der Wirkung scheint
das anders zu sein aber auch mit 25
Prozent hat man nicht den Anspruch ich
bin der nächste Kanzler und jetzt müssen
wir mal gerade gucken wie wir die
anderen mit dazu kriegen sondern da
würde ich ebenfalls empfehlen auf
Augenhöhe mit jedem potenziellen Partner
zu sprechen und wenn Herr Walter bojens
das sicherlich meine Partei Vorsitzende
ist ja nicht Olaf Scholz erkundet die
fdp-mache Voodoo Ökonomie oder was auch
immer heute morgen ich weiß nicht ob das
die Augenhöhe ist und der Gesprächsstil
ist den man im Moment braucht für uns
ist jedenfalls der Wahlkampf mit dem
gestrigen Tag beendet und wir sind jetzt
in der Phase eine stabile Regierung für
Deutschland zu ermöglichen und das geht
nur und das hat mich immer geprägt
mit Respekt vor dem potenziellen
Koalitionspartner und dieser Respekt ist
übrigens auch wichtig egal ob der groß
oder klein ist in Nordrhein-Westfalen
ist der Abstand zwischen uns und dem
Koalitionspartner ein wesentlich
größerer und trotzdem kann man
respektvoll miteinander reden den
anderen seine Punkte machen lassen und
auch deutlich machen dass man nicht
am liebsten alles alleine macht sondern
dieser Teamgedanke auch in einer
Koalition tut gerade Deutschland mit dem
was jetzt ansteht gut
vielen Dank Herr Laschet vielen Dank
Herr ziemiak vielen Dank fürs Kommen
danke schön